hey how are you doing jody
congratulations
um i've got to ask you has is this the
most comfortable
outfit you've ever been able to accept
an award in
the most comfortable and very beautiful
so
i'm super excited i think we were all
excited the whole
this is the best globes ever to be able
to
be home but also it just felt really
real it didn't feel like it was filled
with so much artifice i think people
were kind of
thrilled by the newness and the sort of
life theater of it all
um it's really special
okay the next question goes to jeremy
jeremy parsons from people the show
hey how are you it's good to see you
congratulations
hey there hi thank you hey just loved uh
when you had the acceptance you had the
dog there i wondered how you're
celebrating what's the plan the rest of
the night
uh oh well dinner's waiting for me
downstairs so i think at some point i'm
gonna eat although i'm not very hungry
um we were thinking of maybe just
driving around the city
with the our heads through the sunroof
um kind of like dogs you know that would
be fun
um but mostly i'm just smiling you know
i just feel giddy this is
this is definitely the best globes ever
best gloves ever
and the next one goes to kevin pollowy
from yahoo
okay yes hi jody how you doing
congratulations
thank you i think a lot of people were
surprised uh
that you thanked aaron rodgers uh
tonight in your acceptance speech but
you actually you promised that you were
gonna do that
correct uh is it now can you tell us
about that is that is that because
you're
like just that big of a packers fan or
have you gotten to meet him through
shayleen what can you say about that
i've decided that
not only am i a huge packers fan but i
am
mvp i am competitive mvp with aaron
rodgers
um yes i'm a huge packers fan and i [ __ ]
i
met i just got a very cute video from
aaron rodgers
where he says he's gonna get me back so
i'm looking forward to this
we'll see who wins awesome thank you
and the next question goes to diana
cooper from
us weekly
okay
hi jody how's it going um
so i had to be a
good so i had two questions the first
question was basically just how
supportive has your wife ben
and secondly um you know there's people
are saying that you set up aaron rodgers
with shailene woodley so i was just
wondering if you could clarify your
relationship with the both of them
[Music]
okay what was your first question though
the first part oh
oh how how supportive your wife is
just how supportive your wife has been
oh yeah she's the best
she's the best um i did not set up
shayleen and aaron
i have never met aaron rodgers so um
but it is possible that i do like to
talk about how much
i love the green bay packers and
sometimes i can talk a little bit too
much about that so of course
shailene is very was very aware of my
enthusiasm for the team oh great
oh hello the next one
goes to tell the other ones can you hear
me
yes the next one goes to tyrone okay
goes to tyrone edwards from he talks ctv
all right testing can you hear me
yeah i hear you perfectly okay perfect
uh well i love that you said that this
is the best
globes ever um i i think back to
watching you on the tv you got your dog
your wife uh you're feeling you look
good you feel
good um can you explain the joy
how you felt yeah those shoes are you
see you're living that's living
i i if you can just explain that joy of
winning
um in that environment
you know what i don't know it's
thrilling i mean i think this is
it's really crazy i do think this is the
best globes ever i think that people
feel
like thrilled and kind of like anxious
and excited because they don't know if
it's going to mess up
the technology is going to work or not
and their home
and i don't know it just felt real it
feels
it feels like a pajama party i don't
know what to tell you it feels like a
pajama party
okay and the next one is green sandberg
from the hollywood reporter
hi jody can you hear me
oh hi um congrats on your award uh
i i wanted to ask this ceremony comes in
the wake of a
of an expose that revealed a stunning
lack of diversity in the hfpa
i'm curious how do you feel about that
lack of diversity and what impact do you
fear it has
well i i feel like they really handled
the question really well which is they
listened
um yeah as you know you know the hfpa
is a organization of 80 80 some people
maybe 90 people
um from foreign magazines all around the
world
and um you know the world is
growing and changing and you know
there's a real awakening
and um we're all getting better instead
of worse
so it sounds like the hf is uh you know
open to
to change and that's exciting
okay and the last question goes to
tougher gawk
roger from people magazine
hi jody hey
just want to know what it meant to kind
of win this tonight
and have your family by your side as you
did it did you expect it
how delayed were they talk to me about
that moment
i don't think i've ever been as
surprised by an award ever in my entire
life
this is the most surprising way i've
ever had in my whole life
and um you know mostly because of the
amazing performances by all these women
in this category but
um i don't know i guess i just never
expected i would ever be back here
you know i just never did um uh
when i won the cecil b demille i i i i
remember saying that
you know i don't know if i'll ever be on
the stage again and um
um the hfpa kind of feels like family to
me because
i've been coming since i was you know 12
13
14 years old and um i have a lot of
nostalgia about it so
um once again i just couldn't have been
more shocked i guess i just never
i never thought i'd be here again